foreign
Jacobson Grand Rapids Michigan hi Jacob
how are you
yeah better than I deserved Dave how
about you better than I deserve what's
up
hey so um I just started following you
guys and me and my wife got married last
year and we sold our house and moved to
a less busy area that was actually
cheaper and so we came into kind of a
windfall of money through that so after
our down payment and everything and we
have our our six months Reserve we have
about 60 000 in the bank we were looking
to do something with and uh given my
situation during college I uh qualified
for the full 20 000 uh
relief package to the new Biden uh
student alone forgiveness and obviously
that's in limbo right now so my question
is I have about thirty six thousand
dollars left in student loan debt should
we just pay it off right now or should
we wait to see what happens
okay
um
well the thing I have figured out is
over the years that um
well I mean we just need to preface this
jacob with I'm old okay and I have seen
a lot of promises that were going to fix
my life come from Washington DC uh the
number of them that have materialized is
approaching zero
and so my what I discovered a long time
ago is is that people that wait on the
government to fix their lives generally
have lives that suck
sure and so I you know have you noticed
that this has been dragging out for like
two and a half years now
yeah yeah and that it's now before the
Supreme Court
which is when at what happened after it
went to the Circuit Court which is what
happened after Biden went ahead and just
did it and it didn't work and uh the
timing was always uh suspect around the
midterm elections and all of that so I I
I don't want to be
um Charlie Brown trying to kick the
football with Biden Lucy holding it
if I'm you I want to take control of my
life that so for that reason I'm going
to pay it off if I'm you there's another
reason if I'm you but you would have to
decide this reason but if I'm there
that I would pay it off and it is that I
actually borrowed the money I owe it
sure there's that okay that's a big that
that's that's not little that's a big
one
yeah I guess my thought process was
obviously the
the onus of the bills would be on the
taxpayers right that money has to come
from somewhere I guess if I was already
going to be paying higher taxes anyways
I might as well get the benefit yeah and
the guy the guy that welded your car
together that didn't go to college gets
to pay your student loan with his taxes
and teachers who make pennies
have to pay it in taxes it goes to
everybody not just you yeah so I mean
yeah I mean it's
that's the thing so you again you do
whatever you want I'm we're not going to
argue with you about that uh but you did
call here and ask so you're always going
to get you know what we think because
that's the problem with this thing it's
what it's about the show's about what we
think so
um
and you know I Jay there's a a
percentage of um
um
idiots out there that are gonna they're
gonna be really really upset and say we
were shaming poor Jacob uh we're not
shaming poor Jacob no at all uh I'm just
telling you what I think I think it's
there's an ethical consideration and if
you think ethics is a form of shaming
then you or what is known as a child
because where do you draw the line Dave
where do you draw the line that's the
question
I mean there are government programs
that are in place
uh that offer tax incentives I take
those I don't pay any more in taxes than
I need to so is that unethical no that's
in place and I didn't promise to do
something and then choose to let the
government do it for me that's right I
have not ever
promised to do anything and then chose
to let the government do it for me but
I've taken advantage of a lot of taxes
tax breaks of all kinds anything that is
on the books and is legal I hate taxes
so um but that that is not an there is a
complete difference here is that I did
not sign up and says I owe this right
now you take care of it but you know
Dave a lot of people on the other side
of it people will say well Dave the
student loan companies they were
predatory they took advantage of me they
took advantage of me an 18 year old kid
absolutely talk to that they're absolute
scum they're absolute scum and um on
that basis if uh we're going to be
righteous and holy and forgive student
loan debt we should buy God quit making
the student loans
how can you keep making the student
loans and that's taught me and you'll
see we call it talking about both sides
of your head you know you can't solve a
problem while simultaneously creating it
that's impossible not not without
calling that intellectual dishonesty
right so yeah I mean that which is what
the definition of politics is so there
you go but uh but yeah so I mean
Democrats Republicans alike that you
guys up there if you did anything on the
hill worth doing it would be stop this
program that's right because you're
destroying young lives with it